salut à tous et bienvenue d'envergure
c'est un nouvel épisode
et c'est l'épisode parfait pour qu'est
ce que vous voulez savoir absolument de
la draft si vous n'y connaissez rien
c'est maintenant puisque c'est la foire
aux questions donc comme l'indiquent le
titre c'est une foire aux questions avec
beaucoup de questions et pas mal de
réponses de notre côté c'est parti pour
ce nouvel épisode d'envergure
[Musique]
alors d'abord le come back de ce podcast
c'est celui d'un homme qui a pris
l'avion des dizaines de fois qui a mangé
sans doute une nourriture douteuses dans
un pays loin loin loin à l'est et qui
est revenu alors sans le titre mais avec
une très belle aventure très beau
parcours de la sig
le coach assistant et notre habitués du
podcast romain leroy salut romain salue
donc je veux qu'on va se répartir le
travail que vous allez faire des
questions je faire la foire comme ça ce
sera assez équilibré voilà c'était bien
la russie qu'à manger quoi russie moi ça
m'intéresse quand en fait le rythme il
assez proche du fils d'un championnat
d'europe jeunes en fait donc ça ne va
pas forcément trop dépaysé nous avons
une même menu tous les jours pendant six
jours d'une gorge beaucoup de variétés
voyant navire en a eu il faut absolument
éviter tout pâtisserie avec des couleurs
un petit peu bizarre
et puis bafouée mais les patois c'est un
petit peu les pattes et surtout comme la
fête nationale était le 9 mai il faut
aimer les survols de patrouilles
d'avions de chasse au dessus de l'hôtel
au moment des heures de sieste c'est
aussi notre spécialité locale et bien
sûr la fête de la victoire évidemment
ravi de la victoire en russie
bon félicitations en tout cas pour très
beau parcours avec la sig est tu
passeras denat par les amitiés à bones
ou un rien su rebondir jt de m6 pizza de
sel
voilà exactement m hippie de la
vaisselle l'ancien de notre dame pour
répondre également question à notre
retour tout aussi capilotractée c'est
pas nous c'est un peu une blague sur vos
cheveux messieurs nico est parmi nos
salles uniques au salut tout le monde je
n'ai malheureusement aucun avion qui
surpasse ma maison même 1,9 mais tu es
pour l'endormir pourtant je suis loin
d'orly maintenant je suis retiré dans
l'est dans la forêt mais mais tu allais
en belgique
tout à fait et j'en profite aussi pour
passer un grand bonjour bozic olson
puisque c'était mon chouchou à notre
dame
voilà
il pose y qu'on adorait déjà dans encore
plus évidemment à l'année là aussi ça
dégueulasse à leurs trousses est-ce que
tu as visité un pays étranger récemment
à la normandie bon j'ai été confinés
j'ai visité le lycée dans lequel jouera
reuil bon on imagine la gastronomie
assez similaire à celle de rolls et
rudimentaire aussi effectivement et et
puis pour toute foire aux questions il
nous fallait bien un auditeur est
quelqu'un qui pose les questions que
auquel nous on n'aura pas forcément
pensé auxquelles vous n'auriez pas
forcément pensé puisque on a vous avez
lancé un appel sur les réseaux sociaux
et donc on a pris le deuxième du
concours de pronostics puisque le
premier déjà là c'est romain le deuxième
du concours de pronostics de la march
madness c'est simon il nous vient aussi
de belgique salut simon bienvenus salez
merci présentation d'hier
bon déjà alors est ce que tu as fait ton
bracket totalement au hasard est ce que
tu connaissais un peu la haine c'est est
ce que tu t'es renseigner quand même un
petit retour avant qu'on commence les
questions non pour être honnête je rire
comme la deuxième mais c'est surtout
après la vidéo vous avez tourné avec
first in java peut regarder vos analyses
et donc j'ai fait ça pour fonction il ya
juste sur le dernier le dernier match au
moins serré choisy b le rsa peut aussi
un peu ce qui a joué par rapport à ce
que à tout le monde qui arrive il est
absolument tout un roman vous aviez
choisi bel'or en tête de gondole donc
bravo à vous deux bailleurs ayant un
ancien b lors d'enquêtés oubliez pas
l'heure actuelle le choix
j'étais obligé ce sous peine de
représailles et vu le format de l'ancien
bébé lors je ne vous les risques et
aucun problème est-ce que l'on peut
donner son nom c'était plein incertain
mischael w je le cite ratures cette
petite phrase issue d'un film quand les
gars de 120 kg parle de 60 et coûte donc
bon voilà
maintenant plus sérieusement on a eu une
discussion la quiche justement début de
la march madness sur la perte parce
qu'une nouvelle heureuse comme ça
un très beau parcours sur la relation
régulière et sur les matchs de
conférences de la deûle habituel et
effectivement si on analyse it est assez
juste et je la partage et sur le fait
que bah ça n'avait de valeur qu'on
allant au bout et que lui était persuadé
sur l'état d'esprit de ce qu'il savait
du groupe et sur les notamment les
valeurs défensives et sur la qualité de
quelques joueurs sur l'individuel qui
avait quelque chose à faire donc j'étais
à contre-courant et c c'est d'ailleurs
pour la petite anecdote on a joué on a
joué une équipe en bcl quelques quelques
jours après qui comptait dans ses rangs
l'ancien gone zahia et l'échauffement
était marrant puisque sur le pré
l'échauffement donc en fait quand on est
à + 48 avant le match il s'est pointé en
b lors de la tête aux pieds
et puis un petit peu asticoter son
collègue en fin de semaine sur le live
du match collègue d'en face qui est un
petit peu passent à travers donc c'est
assez je suis rencontrent séparément
évidemment le petit chambrage simon
c'est une foire aux questions
j'étais chargé de trouver un maximum de
questions en plus de celles que j'ai
noté qu'on nous a posés sur sur twitter
on essaiera de répondre à un maximum je
vais juste posé les bases toutes les
questions qui correspondent à au besoin
d'une équipe ou au besoin d'un joueur ne
me répondront pas aux besoins d'un
joueur à la projection d'un joueur en
particulier
sauf exception va pas y répondre pour ça
il ya les podcasts habituel est pour et
pour les besoins des équipes évidemment
on fera des articles futur et des
podcasts futur donc on ne va pas y
répondre maintenant on va rester sur les
questions apprendra à savoir comment
fonctionne la draft et à connaître cette
grave 2021 simon vas-y donne-nous ta
première question tout simplement ok
donc du coup première question c'est
plus un point de vue organisation de la
draft bas quand est-ce que ça va se
dérouler et où ce que cette année ce
sera en présentiel
ou ce que ce sera encore en vie de
conférences comme adsl alors ce qu'on
sait c'est que c'est le 20 juillet jeudi
ce concept parce que je sais quelque
chose qui est possiblement amené à
changer évidemment donc la loterie sait
déjà c'est le 22 juin
théoriquement et la draft le 29 juillet
ce qui signifie les dates de
candidatures doivent être les
candidatures doivent être bouclées une
ou deux semaines avant alan est ce que
tu peux me corriger là dessus et juillet
je crois que c'est une dot pour la haine
sièges et des bus pour pour la n6 oui et
pour les euros c'est une semaine avant
droit de retirer le retirait sa
candidature donc voilà les candidatures
qui vont être nombreuses vas-y une autre
question simon ben justement tu as parlé
de la loterie oui en quoi ça consiste et
qu'elle des équipes risquent d'avoir les
premiers choix cette année a alors à
l'année ce que tu aimes tu as de quoi
répondre à cette question pas alors la
loterie la loterie c'est un système
d'allocation des pics donc pour toutes
les équipes qui n'ont pas fait les
play-offs
donc c'est vrai que ça a été un peu
chamboulé puisque maintenant une vieille
alpines
donc en gros il ya pu vraiment il ya
plus ces équipes qui font les play-offs
en réalité il y en a vingt maintenant
parce que ça va de 1 à 10 dans chaque
conférence est pour les îles qui sont
pas qualifiés pour les play-offs
pourrait pour un petit peu
balou et les choix de draft dans la
loterie donc des meilleurs joueurs du
top 10 avant ses limites je suis avant
la triste et jusqu'au top 14 parce que
si avec ces équipes qui faisait lui
plaît au final 14 qui les faisait pas
c'est en gros pendant les play-offs nba
c'est toujours un soir pendant les
play-offs nba
c'est en gros une minoterie bas comme au
loto ou on fait une simulation du nombre
de chances d'avoir le fer ce pic le 2e
ou 3e ou 4e ce que c'est une brêle sait
sauf que c'est pas une simulation c'est
la seule fois que ça se fait en vrai
c'est comme ça qu'on alloue les les
choix de draft avec une volonté aussi de
la nba qui a été mise en place de dans
leur idée contrer le temps king en un
petit peu monde en pondérant les chances
d'avoir le faire ce qui est à dire quand
dans les autres ligues américaines
talent pire bilan talent furent speak ya
pas deux il n'y a pas de débat la banque
qui peut essayer de mettre bas du
suspense ou où arrivait le temps king
c'est juste des cités deux derniers
bateaux râle une plus grande chance
d'avoir le frère speak n'était pas
obligé les trois derniers ont un des
chanceux légale d'avoir le phare speak
les trois pierres bilan donc quelqu'un
veut prendre la parole
j'ai énormément de réactions l'académie
française qui tient à féliciter alan
pour utiliser les mots et pondéré à
louer et allocation dans une même phrase
c'est vraiment c'est très très rare et
hugues absolument c'était c'était un
trajet qu'énormément de vocabulaire des
mots du gros dictionnaire comme on dit
c'est ça aussi en oui c'est ça la
littérature et la lauter du coup la
longueur du cou justement pour répondre
à une question qu'on a vu sur twitter et
pour rebondir cet philippot qui nous
demandaient comment calcule l'ordre
second tour cède c'est très simple tu
prends les bilans du pire
jusqu'au meilleur le pire bilan a le
choix numéro 31
et ainsi de suite jusqu'à 60 même s'ils
sont souvent échangé
c'est comme ça que ça fonctionne c'est
beaucoup plus simple qu'au premier tour
le pire bilan est le premier choix comme
disait alan comme ça se passe dans les
autres les autres ligues
on va rentrer un peu plus dans le détail
ça c'était le
on va dire le b à ba simon est ce que tu
as des questions voilà un peu un peu
plus peut-être guchez sur l'organisation
des équipes lors de choses donc j'avais
aussi j'étais dernière question c'était
par rapport à votre peu tout ce qui est
scouting et tout ça mais vu que
maintenant on sait comme que les joueurs
ils sont assez piste et avant d'arriver
en nba
la semaine avant la latte raf si je me
trompe pas il ya le travail comme by me
et est ce que ça a toujours une place
aussi importante pour les scouts nba
maintenance cette semaine cette semaine
là où ils sont les choix sont déjà
généralement fait avant avant cette
semaine c'est intéressant nico est ce
que tu peux tu peux expliquer le
processus d'une franchise est ce que
vraiment qu'un événement à une ou deux
semaines de la draft peut changer
quelque chose
c'est vrai c'est vrai que c'est une
question intéressante c'est une question
que moi je me suis souvent posée surtout
au début quand j'ai commencé à
intéresser ce que d'ailleurs la première
fois que j'ai croisé ma chemise je crois
que c'est la première question que j'ai
posée non pourquoi
les scouts américains en ayant
surveiller des joueurs pendant un deux
de trois ans peuvent tout remettre en
question le soir de la campagne où le
pendant le moment là la compagnie on va
dire que tout ne change pas pendant la
campagne mais il ya énormément de points
qu'ils gagnent ou qu'ils perdent c'est
c'est comme ça s contre sa logique on
pas logique peut-être que romain a des
retours d'expérience là dessus mais le
fait de pouvoir les avoir sous les yeux
de les tester
il ya ce côté de celui qui va me
surprendre par sa vitesse mais qui va
décevoir
celui qui saute plus haut qu'on pensait
et du coup effectivement on va peut-être
mettre un coefficient moins important à
ce qu'on a pu avoir comme comme retour
en gardant cette vision de la campagne
peut-être un peu plus importante que ça
devrait être
je suis mais je ne le vois plus ou moins
avec sur joint peut être que jenny cause
c'est à dire que encore plus aujourd'hui
où déjà avancé cette saison les cochons
les expos les coaches par les scouts
non non droit de se déplacer
officiellement et ont été posées par la
liesse des places officiellement il ya
quelques semaines donc sir que les
scouts internationaux alors se base en
europe est en contact direct toujours
par le réseau des consultants et
compagnie donc bon même sont pas pu se
déplacer ils peuvent bosser mais les les
les exécutifs des franchisés les scouts
basé aux états unis
ils ont profité en or depuis quasiment
un an ou presque
donc le fait de pouvoir voir les joueurs
de manière directe pour les européens ou
internationaux au combat insee c'est
comme quelque chose d'important je pense
et puis c'est exactement qu'on gagne
qu'on peut trouver les petites
curiosités sur sur les mensurations sur
un verdure sur un joueur qu a pris de la
taille sur un joueur corée corée corée
évoluer sur différents aspects liés à
millas sa morphologie ou ou à son
morphotype aux excédents externes que
voir les joueurs en bresse a toujours un
intérêt ça toujours un apport de d'infos
supplémentaires c'est encore une
fonderie horne principe le mât drafté
aussi faire gagner des gens loto quand
on décide de faire gagner quelqu'un de
l'auto d'en savoir un maximum changer
l'organisation du draft combine cette
année est conditionné est encore entre
parenthèses selon l'évolution de
l'épidémie aux états unis mais
théoriquement ce sera du 21 au 27 juin
maintenant ce que pour compléter ce que
ce que disait romain on voit souvent des
mensurations de joueurs apparaître sur
les sites des universités sur des sites
aussi d'informations qui ne sont pas
réels en tout cas qui sont différentes
de celles qu'on peut avoir au combat il
ne peut avoir jusqu'à aller 3 4 cm de
différents j'exagère pas quand même
c'est à dire un pouce de différence
entre entre ce qui ce qui est annoncé et
ce qui est réel donc ça c'est très
intéressant
et puis à des mensurations bas que
évidemment que les équipes que
lorsqu'elles font un workout elles
peuvent les prendre chez les joueurs
lorsqu'elles font avoir quatre privé
mais il ya des mensurations aussi qu'ils
sont quasiment aussi importante que
taille poids elles ne sont pas autant
mais par exemple on en parlait dans un
podcast crois l'année dernière la
largeur la longueur des mains on se rend
compte que c'est corrélé à l'adresse
corrélé à wendel ce genre de choses
simon est ce que tu as à ounans rominger
une question complémentaire par dont tu
parlais du fonctionnement des franchises
avec les consultants etc
alors je sais qu'on a déjà parlé dans un
petit test précédent mais il ya aurel
lamboley sur twitter qui demandent
combien de skype par franchise nba au
temps où autant de autant
d'organisations de 40 kg de franchise en
fait en gros vous avez en moyenne à une
moyenne donc tu veux pas faire de
moyenne parce que tu as une franchise
par zones comme boston ou tu n'as qu'un
seul scrutin internationales et à des
franchises haute route en a trois cadres
marc front c'est très variable une
franchise à l'autre tu as tu as une
franchise comme les clippers qui ceux
qui se reposent sur un réseau de secours
tk énormément de consultants c'est c'est
très variable c'est très variable
franchise à l'autre a pas de vérité
générale c'est les organisations qui
dépendent souvent de de dons faites un
parent d'en haut ça dépend ce front de
thiais g m2 qui en sus était en charge
du canton est organisé le front office
est ce qu'un instant gm qui en charge du
scouting ou pas derrière toute la
déclinaison vient de lancer chaque
chaque franchise à son modèle et son
comment dire son sa façon de fonctionner
mon sachant globalement à quelques
exceptions près c'est souvent la
confidentialité qui précédèrent que on
se rend compte que les les plus
efficaces sont souvent les plus discrets
oui puisque discrétion pour récolter des
infos rappelle romain c'est avant tout
cela le travail d'un ce cas où tu les
l'analyse vidéo j'allais dire on peut la
faire
c'est plus tard millions charge dit
exactement que j'y travaille de recharge
intel et comme m'a dit comme a dit le
quelqu'un qui est à l'époque assistant
gm d'une franchise et qui aujourd'hui gm
une autre qui m'a dit qu'ici si tu veux
être scout ou consultant pour avoir une
vie sur les réseaux sociaux faux faut
avoir d'autres aspirations c'est pas
compatible
c'est du mans est alors dans la dans la
veine de la question pour pour toi alan
puisque nico c'est que ce que c'est ton
métier et romain tu tu es à la sig
donc tu n'as pas le temps pour pour
faire ça mais le même aurel lamboley
demande est-ce que vous avez déjà été
contactées ou envoyer des cv pour
devenir ce cas août d'un club ou d'une
université
alan 10 mois est ce que tu as été
contactées ou pas que je m'inquiète un
peu pour que le remplaçant non pas
encore
j'espère pas encore mais pour aller plus
loin dans la réponse en fait alors sur
le plan français et européens les
motiver à envoyer envoyer des cv au club
et tout ça peut être pourquoi pas
quelque chose qui fonctionne mais je
pense que dans le microcosme nba c'est
s'est envoyé une bouteille à la mer
c'est surtout du réseautage ont donc
pour avoir des postes et souvent pour
lier pour être sur l'ailé on va dire des
les listes de candidats surtout arrêtez
moi si je me trompe mais je pense que
c'est surtout et avant tout du
réseautage et en deuxième ligue du
réseau c'est uniquement le réseau voilà
étant donné que c'est un métier où il
faut du réseau c'est ça paraît logique
qu'il faut en avoir pour pour devenir
aussi je citerai pierre mondy j'ai mon
réseau pour offrir à son réseau ma femme
à son réseau on a chacun notre réseau
mais on se mélange pas c'était dans la
7ème compagnie au clair de lune bien sûr
évidemment on l'avait simon est ce que
tu as une question oui je peux partir
c'est un peu plus dans dans la draft en
elle-même et elle va dire les joueurs
qu'est ce qu'on peut attendre de la
draft ici est ce qu on est plutôt sur
une grosse cuve et où ce que c'est le
prodrome sûrement dire dans le queens
ça c'est une question qui est pas mal
revenus alors c'est évidemment hyper
difficile à dire
et on jette un peu des mots en l'air on
voit ce qu'ils retombent parce que
nous ce qu'on aime c'est juste juge et
trois quatre ans après mais on va
répondre quand même alan il est possible
d'estimer un petit peu la valeur d'une
draft à son top 10 généralement je pense
surtout les gens ils se posent cette
question parce qu'on leur a vendu sa
l'année dernière comme une mauvaise rohr
donc comme une draft décevante et qu'on
leur a dit zelaya des super joueurs qui
arrivent pour l'an prochain
tout le monde attend d'ascq ont répondu
oui en fait je pense à cette question
mais dirait que
en fait c'est un peu tout le temps la
même chose plus on s'approche de la vie
en adrar plus en fait des joueurs qu'on
le nombre de jours qu'on voit
potentiellement franche explique-t-il
sans me diminue donc d'un drap
absolument mais je dirais que c'est
quand même une bonne somme une solide
cuvée c'est pour voir les joueurs qui
vont retourner en ciel en europe mais
moi je sais c'est une cuvée avec plus de
potentiel de star que celle de l'année
dernière par exemple que ou que d'autres
et la profondeur est un peu sous côté
show capable on a beaucoup dit qu'ils
avaient pas de pros de profondeur c'est
peut-être parce que c'est des gens
reconnaissaient pas trop - qu'on est
moins vu l'an passé avec la la la
période de draft a été hyper prolongé
donc pendant l'été on n'a pas pu voir
des joueurs qui retourne à initier tout
ça mais moi je trouve que c'est une
c'est une belle cuvée pour nouer et et
alors on nous demande aussi de comparer
cette cuvée à une autre je trouve ça
hyper dur mais la plus logique ce serait
la draft john fitch avec un une
superstar et plusieurs potentiels
joueurs franchise player ou en tout cas
top 30 de la ligue quoi tu la lide nico
pour renchérir là dessus moi ce qui me
ce qui me marque c'est que j'ai
l'impression que la classe
internationale de cette draft est
extrêmement sous-évalué peut-être pas
aux états unis en france c'est certain
parce que du fait de la médiatisation
il n'y a pas de français qui prévu dans
top 20 donc on en parle moins mais met
clairement dans cette classe
internationale t'at 4,5 potentiel fort
son pic ou en tout cas qui peuvent
apporter la valeur d'un fort sens
éthique
ce qui est drôle c'est que alpes et
rensing gones en turquie est très très
critique est sous-évalué on a du mal à
voir en lui un prospect billets alors
que bon on va dire que aux états unis
il a plutôt la cote garuba est peut-être
un peu plus apprécié en espagne mais on
voit surtout ce qui sait pas faire il ya
ya ya plusieurs exemples que vous mêmes
repères cassine alors là par contre
c'est au niveau des états unis cité
assez surpris sur les consensus des
différents gros sites pour les mauves
draft sur certains sites il est milieu
de deuxième tour
il est très très bas par rapport à ce
qui pouvait être annoncés il ya un ou
deux ans il ya certes un certain
consensus qui ne parle pas du goût badji
là où certains le met dans comment dire
fin de premier tour début de deuxième
donc effectivement je suis d'accord avec
toi je trouve cette cette classe
internationale sous sous-évalué dans le
sens où si on la compare à celle de l'an
dernière j'ai l'impression qu'il ya
quand même plus de deux talents et plus
de joueurs qui vont être capables de
faire de faire carrière dans la grande
ligue absolument je suis d'accord avec
toi
simon si on enchaîne sur les
internationaux
on a reçu plein de questions de belges
sur un rebelle alors alors vas-y alors
dit nous qui s'est déjà pourquoi il est
connu en belgique
aubin bellens a un profil quand même on
va dire qu'on comme on aime bien on voir
maintenant comme vous enfin pas dans le
style de victoire non plus comme vous
avez en france mais un assez assez long
grand qui s'est jetée qui a cadets -
dell et qui joue meneur en division en
belgique donc je pense que c'est simon
simon bouillard c'est le kevin durant
est belle
voilà comment on peut faire si on veut
vraiment y mettre un peu de pression
non mais il a annoncé aussi dans les
médias que il table est vraiment sur le
terrain cette année donc je pense que
c'est quelqu'un que qu'on attend nous en
belgique et puis ça fait déjà un petit
temps qu'on a plus de deux jours drafté
c'est le dernier cité axel hervelle je
pense donc c'est un peu
sharp l'espoir c'est à la mode les
meneurs de grande taille
nico tu l'as vu jouer il ya peu plus
tard que quelques jours est-ce que
brence
bryan berg c'est comme ça t'en dis
est-ce qu'il a une chance bla bla bla si
tu sais pas quand est-ce qu'il a une
chance c'est un joueur de en terre
est-ce qu'il a une chance
oui le talent est là clairement il a il
a une capacité à créer pour les autres
qui est assez exceptionnel pour un
joueur de sa taille
donc oui il a une chance après est ce
que aujourd'hui il l'est dans dans la
tête de deux scouts nba bon ben voilà
cent sans dévoiler de secrets
on était j'étais pas tout seul dans le
gymnase dimanche à pourvoir son match
donc je pense que oui il a une chance
après il ya beaucoup de joueurs qui sont
suivies en europe plus qu'ils sont
suivis qui sont drafté forcément donc on
verra mais en tout cas sur le talent pur
oui il a sa place dans la draft
rapidement ça donc tu disais faire jouer
les autres moi j'ai trouvé surtout des
progrès au tir très conséquent de sa
part j'ai joué depuis un ou deux dents
c'était un peu c'était pas catane et
c'était pas du tout et signale ce jeu
raison et là ça parle aux parasites et
équilibrée c'est assez costaud au shoot
et c'est souvent une porte d'entrée en
nba
et puis c'est surtout distance nba ouais
ouais ce qu'ils avaient la capacité à
tirer un peu de partout comme tu l'as
dit vite sa part d'en haut
après les spécialistes du tir il a les
anges qui part à gauche les pieds qui
sont totalement désaxé donc attention
aux yeux
si vous aimez les shoot pur on est on
est loin du geste de ray allen ont donc
maintenant bizarrement le sa part bien
cercle au la rotation
le geste de la main c'est ça finit bien
par contre le bas du corps c'est bagdad
donc c'est un tir assez original mais il
a le tir il a la capacité à créer
parfois j'entends dire que c'est une
sorte de poussettes ski du pauvre je le
trouve moins fantasque que ses skis
après on dit ça surtout parce que c'est
quelqu'un qui est très grand qui est fin
et qui est capable de d'initier des pick
and rolls et c'est surtout là dessus que
qu'on le compare avec beaucoup et puis
il reste plus vieux que beaucoup donc
donc c'est pas le même courbe de
développement on va dire ça va me dire
qu'il est beaucoup bien toumany camara
aussi le belge
je valide romain elle est passée
inaperçue avec la mer cinéma je vais pas
te demander de la répéter c'est toujours
moins bien je disais qu'il était
beaucoup plus vieux aussi beaucoup et
roman tu as déjà entendu parler de ce
belge french blind alpes
bien sûr production du plat pays j'en ai
j'en ai entendu parler je n'ai pas
forcément à celle jouée pour avoir un
avis un avis ferme et définitif non pas
que je ne m'intéresse pas la question
mais qu'un de rayer un petit peu
dantesque depuis quelques mois donc
c'est pas forcément très simple de se
mettre la tête réellement dans le lait
dans les jeunes joueurs mais j'ai bon
espoir pour pouvoir attaquer salon
quinze jours trois semaines pour
rattraper un peu le retard alors à la
nuit sur friends
tu l'as vu ou pas non plus que je ne
connais pas je parlais de toumany camara
qui a un autre forme absolument mais qui
revient pour une année
pour l'année prochaine qui les
transferts où il est pas là les jeunes
qui va jouer à daytona
mais effectivement c'est un joueur si
mon petit espace tu le connais ou le
suis mais il a un potentiel il peut il
pour être drafté ci progresse il a des
outils justement j'avais vu qu'ils
étaient crohas lights cette année et je
me demandais quel et enfin l'intérêt
pour lui de partir de ce jour j'ai pas
c'est pas trop trop compris je sais pas
si vous savez répondre à la question en
vitesse de tissi dayton c'est mieux que
georges ne s'est pas beaucoup mieux
s'est bâti en vrai ça joue mieux pour
lui mais c'est moi je vous posais du
jour - contre des grosses bêtises tu
m'en prends tu m'as tu prends moins de
tholot et dans la télé nationale ouais
ouais
et c'est un vrai bon joueur en moi
j'aime bien son fût son physique de pau
ce cas de gaucher et qui tira il tire
pas mais c'est pas horrible et
physiquement il est vraiment là voilà
absolument absolument un beau physique
et donc pour répondre à ta question
initiale simon on y croit pour elle ce
qui devrait rentrer on va faire un big
board bientôt mais qui pourrait entrer
dans notre prochain un prochain initiaux
notre big board
si on poursuit romain il y avait une
question sur les français tout
simplement
qui alors j'essaye de retrouver
l'intitulé exact de la question mais en
gros qui est susceptible d'être drafté
côté côté français alors susceptible ou
candidats on va partir sur les candidats
donnent dans l'est dans les jambes rang
des ambitions déclarées après pour cette
année il y avait il y avait clairement
juin à béganne keith hackett à paris qui
était lui même si peu aussi la veille
avait coché la draft ursa sur sa feuille
de route qui fait une saison somme toute
assez correcte en pro b donc avoir un
petit peu
avoir un petit peu qu'elle cote on va
donner aux au bonhomme et au fait qu'ils
jouent ans qui joue en pro b parce que
de mémoire j'ai je crois pas qu'on ait
eu un seul joueur drafté deux sortants
de pro b directement séraphin n'ont
jamais joué
gauthier je me trompe peut-être mais
comme ça comme ça ça me revient pas si
tu veux après on est cette année sur un
banc dans le cas de dans le cas de
bégard il est donc revenue à ou paris
basket avec avec son camarade kamagaté
on est sur un joueur qui est sur cette
saison à 10 points 10 points par match
avec il restera trois points qui reste
un petit peu encore qui laisse encore un
peu désirer mais qui est en évolution
légère par rapport à l'an dernier
ce soit sur le pourcentage de survolume
de tir elle a quasiment tripé le volume
de tirs à trois points pris en deux ans
il a augmenté de un peu moins de 2% il
flirte avec les 31 32 s'est pas encore
assez mais c'est déjà intéressant ça
avance dans le drive savant sur un
respect mais gare à après ce que c est
ce que c'est totalement prêt je ne sais
pas eu qu'à une encore un petit peu de
choses à gommer dans le jeu ont ils
jouent diminuer de plus que l'an dernier
mais il est quasiment né quasiment
doublé son ca moyenne de balles perdues
aussi donc pas pas forcément super
simple mais bon un joueur qui était
candidat et qui qui semble candidat
légitime après faut voir là dedans la
transposition et voilà presque un petit
peu autour comme prospecte toujours
pareil parce que ceux projetés se dire
se dire candidats et est intéressé
ensuite socopa roseaux ya toujours une
petite a donc et si les rastas nous l'an
prochain je ne sais pas dans les gens
qui sont
qui sont également un petit peu sur les
radars pour cette année ou plus tard il
ya eu 2 makoun dookie à cholet ok sur un
profil totalement différent c'est un
joueur intérieur je dire à profil
défensif rebondeur plus que plus
qu'autre chose encore un petit peu
frustré offensivement il ya des choses
qui se construisent et même s'il a
montré a à plusieurs reprises qu'il a
une capacité à mettre des points mais
c'est encore assez assez unidimensionnel
même s'il a un embryon on tire sur
lequel vont peut-être se reposer plus
tard mais on renvoie aux podcasts
d'ailleurs qu'on avait faits sur sur
makoun tous si vous voulez en savoir
plus voir un joueur qui est encore assez
jeune homme en baskets un globalement
mais kkk parking des qualités physiques
au dessus de la au dessus la moyenne de
ce qu'on peut trouver
globalement sur à son âge sur les sur
les européens après derrière on va un
petit peu plus loin on est sur des gens
plus jeunes ont un matthieu gaudin
peut-être qu'il voulait tenter cette
année mais ça me semble que le meneur de
ducey serbes derrière l'arc et kasaï
alors il ya blanc en en seria malcom
cazalon qui est acquis abeba mais un
média d max pardon qui a déclaré cette
année aussi la tique affiche ses
ambitions vertement
et puis il ya une plus sain il ya ismaël
kamagaté donc voir peut-être l'an
prochain mais ça me paraît je serais
surpris qu'on ad'autres hippiques s'est
taillé après qu'un joueur puisse se
glisser sur un sur un début de deuxième
tour début milieu deuxième tour pourquoi
pas mais bon la saison et as encore une
15 10 12 matchs à jouer les joueurs sont
révolus en situation est ce que mes gars
a intérêt à oulches ans pour y aller
cette année ce qui peut y aller l'an
prochain c'est encore une fois c'est pas
moi de le dire moi je
il fait partie des joueurs qui
ambitionne de ce qui serait l'évolution
logique après ce qu'il aura pas besoin
d'un passage par les caisses du pays
pour confirmer des choses et pour
peut-être aussi à moins de passer un
palier difficile à dire
en tout cas voilà c'est sans se
prononcer sur la valeur des joueurs
voilà petit prêt à peu près le panorama
con qu'on peut avoir en août et en août
un jeu c'est pas faut pas hésiter débat
besson et strazeele strazeele exact
strazeele mais tu seras des campus on a
joué ya pas très longtemps
pareil ce serait moi je ne verrai plus
sur un sur une projection en fin de
deuxième tour il a il a eu une année un
petit peu en dents de scie il jouait pas
mal l'an dernier un petit peu moins
cette année bon ça reste un joueur sur
lequel sur lequel on peut garder l'oeil
parce qu'il ya eu des il ya eu des
choses très intéressante en euroligue et
des choses intéressante en championnat
aussi quand il a du temps de jeu et en
général il est efficace il est rentable
donc c'est pas mal besson c'est un
profil différent une vraie capacité à
scorer un tir à un petit peu plus en
difficulté parfois sur les aspects
défensifs
je le vois plus je le vois plus se
tailler taille euroligue lui pour les
haut niveau mais il capté par comptable
est des moins ce qu'on parle de pro b
pour pour begarin la saison 2 de emi un
floor de progrès dessin la saison du bo
besson elle et elle est en tous points
en tout point impressionnante dans une
équipe qui était bien drivé par julien
mahé laqué qui joue les premiers rôles
depuis le depuis le début de l'année en
pro b à tel point que finalement c'est
plus une surprise ainsi devenu un petit
peu la type e la normale et hugo besson
pour avoir un petit un petit rapport
chiffré ces dix quasiment 19 points avec
une répartition tirade sur a3 qui est
correct il prend 14 tirs par match si on
pense être au point
il est quasiment 1 37% à 3 il va sur la
ligne il prend des rebonds il fait
quelques passes on sait c'est pas
inintéressant pour le très très haut
pour le très haut niveau je parle de
verbier ce sera plus sur les qualités
athlétiques peut-être et la capacité à
défendre que que je pense qu'il peut il
peut perdre de peu par un petit peu au
niveau de sa cote
mais bon
encore une fois on a un joueur qui voit
là cet âge-là scoré à ce point c'est un
joueur quant à elle marqué néant calé en
2001 qui a dit cela dit du printemps
match en pro b
dans une équipe qui est leader du
championnat parce qu'il est pas non plus
à 10 du point dans une étude de batna
l'eau il ya quand même des petites
choses à pas à pas ignoraient
l'existence
bien sûr bien sûr il ya des signes nico
tu voulais ajouter quelque chose sur
rupture béguin non je voulais ajouter
une chose sur le fait que dit zahia
quand il y avait été drafté progrès à
voile soit avec cannes avait exactement
là dans ce cas dans le cadre d'ailleurs
mené sur un but on est sur du deuxième
ouais on est sur un fait la chaussure du
stage pure et simple alors de tête c'est
quoi du au deuxième tour et atlanta
car une carte du quatrième milieu de
sueur du milieu deuxième tour
effectivement mais quand alors je vais
je vais condé ray pour reprendre le mot
d'alan je vais pont des arts et je vais
modérer mes propos quand je quand je
parle de draft est sortie de pro b je
parle d'avoir une capacité de projection
et de rôle tout de suite s'élançant ça
que je dis moi j'avais passé
suffisamment de temps pro b à titre
personnel ou professionnel pour surtout
pas dévaluer important de champion parce
que on peut développer des jeunes
joueurs que ce soit par il fait très
bien avec avec jc prades loi l'a fait
aussi il ya plein de clubs en premier
qui travaillent travail correctement
donc c'est de ce côté là de ce côté là
y'a pas de soucis c'est un champion
n'est pas mal de coach en a reçues
guillaume qui hérisse car moi aussi
quelqu'un mais qui bosse bien donc il ya
des vrais coacher les vrais joueurs donc
je ne dédaigne pas le truc c'est
vraiment pour moi l'idée d'être capable
de faire le gab finalement entre pro b
et joueurs nba tout de suite derrière
oui parce qu'on voit que l'adaptation à
nba même pour des joueurs qui ont une ou
deux années pros dans les pattes on
pense à ces coups on pense à d'autres si
c'est pas toujours évident et ça peut
prendre du temps donc plus plus le fossé
est large plus il faut avoir les épaules
solides quoi accompagnant mes joueurs de
qualité tous également en tout cas sans
aucun souci
bien sûr le prendre avant sur ce type
c'est ça c'est pas parce qu'il ya pas de
projeter loterie que c'est pas une
génération tellement annoncé sa science
n'est pas surtout pas dire ça parce que
je dis pour moi pour moi pour moi besson
pour ne parler que lui c'est une famille
c'est un contexte basket c'est un joueur
de jeep élite très solide en devenir a
très très court terme un pour moi que la
projection pour moi c'est tous ces
joueurs soient besson ce soit makoun
d'eau que ce soit begag soit kamagaté
strazeele ou même case allons cesser des
joueurs qui feront carrière et qui font
carrière à haut niveau et c'est encore
une fois je sais pourtant coupé c'est ce
qu'on nous intéresse ici on dit encore
on le répète on parle beaucoup de la
draft parce que c'est là où son drafté
on va dire les plus hauts potentiels ou
sont sélectionnés parmi les plus hauts
potentiels mais on regarde aussi
l'ensemble des jeunes joueurs et c'est
pour cette parfois on va vous parler de
joueurs nba qui n'iront jamais un billet
mais qui pourront faire éventuellement
carrière en europe à la retombée l'ont
condamnée pour moi c'est laisser des
solides joueurs professionnels en
devenir a des joueurs de qualité avec
des qualités et des défauts bien sûr
avec peut-être pas là on va dire la
jauge la jauge et levier sur la
programmation mais ça reste un joueur de
haut niveau et des bulles des joueurs
qui bosse pour ça donc c'est surtout ça
qu'il faut retenir sur les autres
français alors de toute façon sur les
français on va faire un voire deux
podcasts spécifique pour bien expliquer
qui est qui qui a quelques capacités qui
a une belle projection etc
alan sur les français de nba puisqu'il
ya d'autres candidats aussi peu que
roman a cité qui évolue à l'université
il fonce johanna yayi olivier sarr et
joe hachem balle à son chum voilà qui
sont candidats pour le moment on peut
renvoyer à la vidéo qu'on a fait avec
faire c'est absolument
on en a parlé on en rencontre
quarantaine de minutes et volait bas
aie aie aie surfe sur sa belle saison sa
march madness
il conseille aux divers essais des
cursus terminé et donc ils ont décidé de
ne pas utiliser la cinquième année
potentiel collins il pouvait leur
accorder de de passer pro et puis et
puis à une balade qui voit la grosse
saison rébuffat lots et bons qui qui va
tester sa cote avec la lui il a vraiment
étonné par contre ça sont attend sous
peu devant émis la possibilité de
revenir et c'est ça ou les trois autres
jim webb pour préciser un peu en gros la
nba
enfin la n6 et autorise le joueur à dire
qu'il est candidat à la draft et ensuite
à revenir à condition qu'il prenne un
agent certifié par la haine scié on tend
à janvier un agent que la liste ce que
l'assiette
voilà donc c'est toujours aussi la n 6
et 1 c'est brouillon
voilà on va pas s'étendre là dessus
simplement voilà il ya des règles josh
m'bala peut revenir à palau et ici on
aime cette fac on peut espérer qu'ils
reviennent ce qui sort d'une excellente
saison en double-double duflot c'est
assez impressionnant une belle
domination à l'intérieur donc voilà
c'est pareil ce sont des candidats plus
au deuxième tour peut-être cailly dans
certains cas et vue est vu en fin de
premier tour sur conscience chez
certaines personnes me go way
alex je voudrais juste rassurer le fan
club d'al ain si il a une petite voix
c'est dû à la blessure de john
variations dioxine juste la laine sur
ton sur ton bord de ces cazalon où c'est
à yayi qui est le plus aux français
classé casablancaise elle s'est mal
comme case en case allongé au premier
tour la prochaine offre pour l'instant
faut que j'aille revoir un peu ses
derniers matches avec mega l'ex oméga
b-max méga superb est toujours un nom
différent vlcc cazalon ben génération
2001 qui était un peu le troisième
bonhomme du trio avec maledon hayes dans
les compétitions de jeunes qui a un
petit passage raté en belgique s'était à
nouveau trois points nico c'est ça il
étale aujourd'hui à louvain qui ensuite
il a heureusement mes gars l'ex qui est
il ya pas mal de prospects joue avec
d'autres prospects qui vont sûrement se
faire racheter joue avec des joueurs
déjà drafté qui sont stache comme les
monténégrins marcos simonovic ou qui a
été drafté par chicago n'ont pas et
ouais j'aime beaucoup son profil
personnellement donc pour moi il peut
vraiment et je pense qu'il a le profil
type pour plaire à des années à des
front office américain
c'est intéressant et c'est la même
génération
je pense que les matches sont toujours
sur youtube d'allergies sont tous les
défis balle u17 avec azéma il est mal et
dont il ya le film a eu 18 ou là il
était par contre le meilleur
l'efsc l'option numéro une parce qu'il
n'est pas à l'aise par malin l'euro u18
en grèce par contre je me permets
c'était sur place le meilleur tu pousses
un plan non mais il est il était il
allie il avait les clés du camion autres
ce qu'ils avaient quand même un certain
moussa diabaté
ouais mais c'est difficile pour un
intérieur de revoir les clés qu'un
moussa diabaté donc comme respect à
suivre l'année prochaine côté français
par michigan qui jouera à michigan qui
est allé une des sept huit plus grosses
factures en termes de médiatisation je
pense aux états unis même s'ils sont ils
font aussi football mais ils sont bien à
fond sur de basket également d'autant
que le coach et juwan howard pour ce
qu'est pas suivi simon est ce que tu as
d'autres questions sur les
internationaux puisque on est partis
là-dessus la moi j'en ai sélectionné
deux sur twitter est ce que tu as
d'autres questions là dessus ou pas vous
avez justement une question pour
reproduire ce pour rebondir sur ce que
vous avez dit est ce que vous pensez que
la pandémie ça comme joue un rôle
puisque vous dites que la classe un peu
ce côté
est-ce que vous pensez que le fait qu'il
puisse pas se déplacer tout ça ça a
peut-être joué un rôle sur sur la
cotation en nba de la place à une
question en main le bouton mieux c'est
un peu ça peut ça peut ça peut ça peut
ça peut mais les gens se les coûts
encore une fois les scousers dépasse un
petit peu maintenant
donc le seul avantage c'est que malgré
tout les jeunes joueurs ont joué un peu
partout les gens ont été exposés les
championnats ont parfois été un peu un
peu haché avec des blessures des choses
comme ça nous des joueurs se sont
montrés après peut pas enlever que tu
peux pas tu veux pas tu peux pas mentir
le fait qu'à un moment les flèches de
géra pas de protectionnisme mais tu vas
plus fort plus facilement et de rareté
des gens que tu as vu inévitablement
donc si les scouts peuvent se déplacer
sur le sur le côté sur toute la partie
est de scier compagnie qu'ils ont vu les
joueurs un niveau équivalent
inévitablement diarra vers les derniers
jours us mais ça pousse à pompe et après
j'ai envie de te dire un joueur un
joueur de bonne qualité mais non drafté
façon il arrive toujours à la surface on
s'est quand même rare aujourd'hui
réussir à passer totalement entre les
mailles du filet et de ne pas y arriver
j'en al'inverse peut arriver par contre
des gens qui soient un petit peu trop
hype et où un petit peu surcoté qui
finalement se retrouve à être là où on
les attendait pas et puis là où
peut-être il ne pas être c'est déjà
arrivé mais l' inverse l'inversé plus
rares donc lieu l'évaluation permanente
de des jeunes mais également des free
agent des gens qui sont encore en âge de
de rentrer dans le contexte leur ligue
de faire des traits linkem de fer li min
kemp et c'est un risque jusqu'à djigo
sichi attractif financièrement quelque
part pour des joueurs être pour des
jeunes jours des joueurs de standing
intermédiaire donc pense que des
passerelles y en a aujourd'hui vraiment
passé à travers vu le maillage concerter
les franchises du gdr du monde en
général
sa pelouse un peu jouer ça peut jouer
mais je pense pas que ce soit
rédhibitoire pour la carrière d'un
joueur nécessaire alors on a une
question là dessus je vais la pause et
annie qu une question de sinnoh ce qui
dit est ce que vous pensez que les
joueurs vont de plus en plus à l'est
soit en j-league soit à l'étranger
plutôt que d'aller en n 6 et puisqu'on a
vu les succès passés on peut aussi
rajouter dans la question de le players
programme de en australie en nba
je vais retrouver mes mots et et voilà
est-ce que qu'est-ce que selon toi ya
une balance qui est en train de
s'effectuer du côté des prospects qui
soient internationaux ou américains même
si tu es plus la vision sur les hauteurs
le succès de la team in it devrait faire
des émules
donc après j'ai malheureusement pas de
boule de cristal mais je pense que il va
y avoir un peu plus de joueurs
effectivement qu'ils vont qui vont
vouloir aller comment dire récupérer
entre guillemets ce qui devrait toucher
à une sieste c'est à dire un peu
d'argent donc ça se fait en australie et
que ça soit sur la ligue
oui je pense que la tendance va être de
moins par tirant sur deux est en tout
cas la question maintenant se pose alors
qu'elle se posait au début les gens
pensaient que ce match serait pas ça
ferait pas la faire là quand on voit les
feedbacks des des commandeurs de front
office et nba sur le leclerc qu'ils ont
pu avoir de d'avoir des devoirs
les futurs drafté dans un environnement
et de billets entouré par des joueurs
plus vieux face à des gens plus vieux ça
serait étonnant
et puis aussi vu le la hauteur de draft
à laquelle les joueurs qui ont choisi la
g-league et c'était de draft et ça
risque effectivement de donner des idées
qui tape sur son clavier roman parce que
j'étais en train de dire en parlait sur
notre groupe de discussion de l'asie
falloir pour cela je vais faire le lien
avec un film si vous n'avez vu fils
money ball avec avec brad pitt
sur justement incroyable sur la gestion
d'une franchise sur la france et sur la
franchise d oakland athletics
n'hésitez pas à aller le voir c'est une
merveille ce film et puis bassam combien
ça met en images un petit peu le côté
conte qu'on ignore que la gestion d'un
front office en fait
alors bon c'est au baseball oui c'est
des réalités différent du basket certes
mais c'est comme super riches et par
rapport à ça je fais bien ce que le
baseball aujourd'hui à un système là que
la nba veulent tendre dessus ça ne me
surprendrait pas parce que au baseball
ou littéralement les gros joueurs ont
chois en fait en sortant de high school
de se faire racheter
et dans ce cas-là de partir jouer dans
les ligues mineures et c'est récupérable
et d'être rémunéré tout de suite et
ainsi de suite
ou de faire l'impasse sur le raf est
d'aller à la fac et de tenter le coup
après derrière et aujourd'hui le
baseball un système de développement
n'en pense qu'on s'en veut de ce qu'on
veut de ce sport mais le baseball à un
système de développement par rapport à
ces liminaire un système de montée
d'essence de passerelles et surtout de
deux de scouting qui est très très
intéressant et qui je pense peut
peut-être préfigurer de ce qui peut
arriver à l'ennemi à moyen terme parce
que six sets 6-7 ce projet de djelic
fonctionne et qui se rendent compte que
c'est viable et inévitablement ils
perdre moins d'argent à mettre les
gammes en couveuse là pour ensuite céder
raft et parce qu'ils peuvent les
observer ainsi de suite
la logique économique reprendra le
dessus et peut-être que justement la
même évolution les initiés sur certains
aspects institutionnels et et les
sportifs va aller vers ça je sais pas ce
que tu en penses à l'amt était là comme
un regard sur le sport universitaire aux
états unis qui est plus poussé que le
mien mais là est révolu un petit peu à
la n'est peut-être pas assez vite
l'ansi évolué jeu pour cela les a évolué
selon les états surtout c'est ça aussi
c'est un état fédéral
donc ya pas les mêmes droits partout
j'aime bien la comparaison avec le
baseball
c'est le truc c'est qu'en fait le
baseball les chaque franchise a comme tu
l'as dit
ah les cinq six équipes en ligue mineure
en gros il ya des étages où tu où tu
peux monter le souci est risqué et ce
qui est unique avec le basket cclat
jillings ils ont créé une équipe parce
que tu peux pas les faire jouer dans les
équipes qui pour ensuite les drafté
bravo baseball ils sont directement
draft et d'ailleurs qui peuvent être
achetés deux fois c'était draft en
sortie de lycée et que tu acceptes pas
tu vas là à l'université mais tu peux
encore présenter à la draft
c'est pas un nom définitif là où si tu
te fais des robes situe si tu vends ou
djelic dans la team is nigh tu t'es pas
fait drafté parce que si tu te fais
drafté et qu'ils peuvent attendre et
dans son équipe de jean et gaza qui est
intéressant et qui est novak nouveau
avec la la team des ligues mais ce qui
est sûr c'est que pour écouter pas mal
de jeunes voir pas mal de jeunes de
parler de la possibilité d'aller voir
s'entraîner contre des pros est dans un
système pro c'est vrai tout le monde
vante le cinquième des très bonnes
infrastructures dans beaucoup
d'universités mais c'est pas pareil que
que s'entraîner tous les jours de faire
que ça être focus dans la carrière de
basketteur avec en plus d'opportunités
dans le système sigma itil et ils ont
dit qu'ils pouvaient ensuite leur donner
une bourse pour faire des études de plus
tard c'est pas non plus une croix
complète sur sur le système d'études
mais ce qui est sûr c'est que ça
chamboule complètement et que c'est
parce qu'en fait aux états unis le
système la formation académique et se
fait au même endroit que la formation
athlétique
parce que y'a pas c'est parce que c'est
historique ça se passe comme ça depuis
le 19e siècle ils ont pas le modèle des
centres de formation des choses comme ça
qu'on a en europe mais c'est quelque
chose bouge parce qu'ils voient que il
ya des modèles alternatifs que ça marche
et là c'est vrai il comme l'a dit nico
doha jeff green et kumming et ils vont
se faire de rester dans le top 10 ça
maintenant pour ce qu'on veut de ces
jours là il aurait sûrement été drafté
aussi en avant un ancien mais toujours
est il qu'ils vont être drafté au en
ayant fait cette expérience m'a donc ça
peut vendre le projet aux autres et on
voit même qu'il ya des internationaux
que ça commence à intéresser y remédier
m cette année 1,1 philippins et un
indien
mon équipe du domaine que balou philippe
la jouer en
l'année prochaine il va lui va jouer en
europe que hors adelheid il va y avoir
des détails pour angie be sûrement c'est
quoi ces lettres les 36 e r r 6 6 1
c'est ça oui messieurs je vous propose
de jeu vous propose pas j'ai décidé je
veux qu'on va couper ce podcast en deux
comme ça en publiant deux fois juste
on va finir sur les internationaux après
on abordera la question vraiment bas
raft de 2021 plus cotés côté américain
il y avait une question sur les masques
et à nico est ce que rapidement tu tu
peux dire je sais que tu aimes bien donc
pourquoi tu y crois puisque il ya il ça
fait pas mal de buzz au portugal fall de
base je vais peut-être me calmer mais
disons qu'il ya une communauté
portugaise qui nous qui nous écoutent
tissu de basket et qui qui aimeraient
bien le voir se serrent draft
pourquoi alors pourquoi j'y crois j'y
crois à mon avis autant que alan n'y
croit pas à l'année moi on se fait la
guerre
moi j'aime que les gros baba et avec
raison il me dit souvent que c'est plus
la mode est passée c'est dur que tu me
dises pourquoi j'y crois parce que en
fait plus je le regardais plus je me dis
qu'il est lourd et qu' il y les papas ou
si il y là il a cette lenteur de
décision qui peut être un vrai problème
mais mais par contre ce qui me fait
continuer à garder espoir c'est que
défensivement c'est le joueur idéal dans
la raquette il un timing de contres très
important il a un corps qui le rend
assez difficile comme on dira à
contourner il est comme ça où tu es
quand il faut que ça outre les mecs sont
derrière lui c'est terminé quoi il fait
de 14 il a quoi de m 24 ans vainqueur
donc franchement voilà défensivement si
on était au handball moi je le draft
direct et lorsque le méchant
les séquences défensives
maintenant on l'a vu sur le début du
match mais premier tour de march madness
contre texas tech
si mes souvenirs sont bons ils les deux
premières actions du match
il tente de poing long et il fait 2 sur
2 donc pourquoi pas mais mais en tout
cas si j'y crois c'est pas pour ce
qu'ils nous proposent offensivement
c'est pour ce qu'il apporte des
sentiments d'une très belle année à utah
state dans la mountain west conférence
puisqu'il tournait à 15 points 10
rebonds
c'est très rare de tourner en double
double en en acier on n'enchaîne pas les
triples doubles comme au niveau du
dessus des allusions à l'actualité
3 quasiment trois passes décisives de
moyenne plus de trois comptes de moyenne
et effectivement tu me fais rebondir là
dessus voilà s'il peut y avoir une
éclaircie sur l'année la troisième année
de de keita en ciel c'est là pour bâtir
le la progression la place qu'on a pu
voir au poste où il est effectivement et
qu'il ya trois passes et il est il et il
a tellement été doublés que je pense
qu'il eût voilà où il travaille aussi sa
part et de la part du staff et
maintenant il est capable de ressortir
proprement et ce qu'ils ont et ce qui
fait de lui donne une corde en mon spi
progression constante que ce soit dans
le jeu aux tirs aux lancers francs il à
71% en maintenant le statut est
important de voir les joueurs continuer
à progresser
romain c'est un truc qu'on pense pas
peut-être pas assez souvent à regarder
mais c'est un joueur qui continue à
progresser ça veut dire que c'est un
joueur qui travaille se dire que c'est
un joueur qui a un bon état d'esprit en
way to dépens après la progression qu'on
quantifie mais en général oui peinture
bon on se met dans le gymnase
j'aime bien les mots comme ça à moins
que 18 écoles gymnases partir on se met
dans le gymnase et qu'on fait en sorte
deux si on travaille à bonne escient et
comment encadrer
on peut faire l'exploit dé des joueurs
j'en vois gens voient souvent
dire ouais mais je comprends pas je fais
du rap ainsi faire du rap c'est juste
rester une demi heure de plus à la sage
shootait trois fois puis discuté ça va
pas par contre les gens qui travaillent
sérieusement de toute façon visiblement
partie ment la valeur travail et les et
elle est présente chez les joueurs c'est
toujours plus facile mais ça je dirais
qu'il ya aussi tout un travail
d'accompagnement autour c'est pour ça qu
encore une fois on y revient le fit est
important quand on se fait de rareté
mais également sur le port pour qu'on
choisit avant sur le parcours qu'on
essaie d'entreprendre avant le fait de
pouvoir se met dans un contexte où on
sait qu'on sera accompagné contre norad
et les coachs au tour et ainsi de suite
c'est quand même quelque chose
d'important je veux dire on a eu on a eu
il ya sin souvent dans le sur le podcast
aujourd'hui on sait très bien que quand
on va quand on va à l'image par exemple
d'accompagner telle et telle façon nous
à strasbourg on a un process de travail
aussi qui est en place maintenant les
joueurs en sont conscients les mecs qui
viennent chez nous savent comme ont
travaillé comme on va travailler dans le
futur sert qu'à un moment il faut être
capable aussi de vouloir avoir des
joueurs de qualité c'est bien avoir des
joueurs qui ont discours l'intention de
dire qu'ils veulent travailler c'est
bien aussi
mais la mise en oeuvre est aussi
important de collisions intention d tout
le monde tout le monde te dit il faut
bosser tous les joueurs tous disent
qu'ils veulent bosser après ces caisses
qui met dedans comment ils sont moi j'ai
vu j'ai été témoin de la situation et
des joueurs des genoux et je vais
travailler mais quand tu les prends pour
faire du rab au quotidien serrage peut
pas trop là j'ai quitté la géci l'agessa
voilà les gens veulent bosser me base
pas donc le la mise en avant c'est ce
que j'appelle souvent donc c'est souvent
le les propos qu'il tient avec les
jeunes joueurs ou les jeunes jose en
équipe de france c'est à dire ses
discours d'intention qu'est ce que tu
fais concrètement sur quoi tu es capable
de s'engager concrètement dans ta vie de
tous les jours pour montrer que tu veux
bosser c'est là c'est là où c'est
souvent le la différence entre un joueur
moyen est un vrai joueur poster je vais
la faire et c'est aussi là où tu fais la
différence entre un mec qu'il ya
peut-être l'intention de travailler mais
qui veut pas trop en faire non plus puis
suit il veut vraiment arriver aux
pionniers ou et qui a vraiment envie de
de faire quelque chose de son 2 2 son
talent ou justement de compenser
peut-être le manque de talent et d'aller
plus loin donc c'est avant tout de
l'état d'esprit mais aussi le contexte
et l'accompagnement qu'on peut lui
donner
on peut dire ce qu'on veut aux joueurs
si les mecs sont pas encadrer
correctement ou si l'on parlait que des
coaches qui qui les accompagnent
convenablement
c'est c'est très difficile et je citerai
julien monclar pour finir qu'il disait
si on les écoute tout le monde est un
bosseur mais seulement il faut savoir
détecter lequel les vraiment on va dire
on renvoie aux podcasts qu'on avait fait
avec avec lui avec guillaume et avec ton
patron pour nicolas effectivement loi
qui me semble-t-il à gagner demain soir
donc félicitations puisque nous
enregistrons le mardi 11 mai c'est la
fin de la première partie on va revenir
pour la suite de ce podcast foire aux
questions
donc avec nico avec romain avec alan et
avec notre questionnaire simon pour pour
évoquer les questions étaient plus
philosophique de cette grappe 2021
parler des joueurs du top 5 et c'est
donc à la semaine prochaine puisqu'il
sera publiée une semaine plus tard nous
évidemment langil dans la foulée à plus
tard